how you doing buddy what's the deal why
is everybody making fun of you
oh because of his vest hey bro nothing
wrong with that vest that's your girl
right here
you're gonna stay roommates you keep
wearing like that
I thought that was your girl and you
weren't cheating on her so you wore the
most uncomfortable piece of clothing
that could possibly exist
she picked it out why are you friend
zoning this man like that
you're a good looking guy he'd be very
lucky to be with a guy like this maybe
what does he do for a living let me ask
you that first you bartend yeah you
could do better
yeah
what do you do for a living
Barista son y'all belong together I take
it back
y'all could raise a little family you
work in the day he works at night you
make drinks for people going to
work he make drinks for people that just
lost their job it's a whole balance you
guys got